hey guys it's Charizard and today I'm
going to be talking to you guys about
Wolfenstein the new order now this game
did come out a couple weeks ago now but
I've been playing through watchdogs and
murdered saw suspect at the moment and I
just can't stop thinking about how I
prefer to be playing Wolfenstein so I
thought that I would talk to you guys
about it and I reviewed it for work as
well but I'm doing it again and I should
mention that that's saying something
because I am not in any way an FPS
person I usually don't like them that
much so this is kind of a big deal so
first of all the bust like four or so
hours of the game are super boring you
start off in this turret mission with
this guy you don't know barking orders
at you in a world war where nothing is
particularly explained it's just like
yeah Nazis fight them that bad I promise
and it's all very overly action-packed
without any substance and yeah but it
gets a lot better so it's at a point
where you get brought in by the
rebellion that this game sort of starts
getting good there are a collection of
super odd but surprisingly well fleshed
out characters who will have different
purposes and different meanings and
different influences that are actually
you know quite in-depth the base itself
is hidden under the city where there's
this massive Nazi it's not even a
revolution any more than RTS have
actually won world war two and that's
what the game is set in so I guess you
spend the rest of the game so I'm trying
to get rid of the Nazis and find some of
your old World War two but and this is
where the stealth comes in
you could probably play a majority of
this game solely using the stealth
mechanics which are really really well
polished you can sneak up to an array of
enemies and take them out from behind
and then eventually you can start
throwing knives which is just as cool of
course because it's Wolfenstein there is
a lot of ridiculousness where you can
like jewel wield automatic shotguns and
assault rifles and nobody could do that
and I mean you pick up armor I'm just
like chunks of metal that are laying
around you're like well that'll do it's
just good to go
there are also really really large
chunks of it where there isn't actually
any combat at all so you'll spend a lot
of time solving these really simple
puzzles mostly with a gun that's called
a laser Kraftwerk I feel like if German
people heard that it would probably
sound really dumb in an Australian
accent laser Kraftwerk so bad I was that
russian week that might have been
brushing and
and some environments you can only get
through by using that so for a while it
can be a little bit perplexing and the
environments are really varied there's
like a weird underwater vault where you
have to unlock these ancient secrets
that have it locked away forever and
then there's a concentration camp that
you have to like break into to bust
someone out who is important to your
cause you can also go to space and at
some point like there's these flying
enemies that if you blow one up the
explosion won't blast you backwards and
I was just like ah gravity the game is
kind of flawed in that there's an
underwhelming lack of emphasis on the
naty's actual influence so you're like
told you're fighting against Nazis and
they're like are the Nazis of won and
are the Nazis are so damn evil but you
never really see that they just tell you
that and I think that's like a rule in
storytelling that you're supposed to
show not tell and they never really show
you any of the evil things that the
Nazis have done which seems like a weird
thing to complain about there not being
enough of beyond that there also aren't
that many varieties of enemies and the
enemies aren't interesting in any way
they're just now it sees and even the
floors that I meant just can be very
easily excused because I feel like it
adds a lot of depth and I guess
personality where a lot of other
shooters seem to fail though that said
it is also a very good shooter like as a
shooter mechanics are great as a stealth
game the mechanics are great too well I
guess I wouldn't have played this if I
didn't have to review it but now so far
in 2014 it's probably my favorite game
of the year obviously that's massively
subject to change because everything
major comes out at the end of the year
Wolfenstein the new order and child of
light definitely my top two so far
watchdogs is extremely disappointing by
the way but that's it for me today you
guys I hope you enjoyed this quick
little review of a game that I have been
gushing over I'll see you guys next time
bye